i went to turnbull canyon this weekend
oh yeah how is everybody else i saw it
i don't know man i just read that it was
scary and i was like did you just drive
there just to go there yeah that's so
[ __ ]
that's just been my mood lately clearly
i don't care about views anymore
i'm just doing it over the phone you
gotta go in the night um
you can't you can't go in the night i
mean you can but you know yeah you gotta
be one of those like
you know j-station type [ __ ] where
you're like visiting turnball at night
yeah i can say candidly the um
that place at night would be scary
because the homes around there look like
it looks like a disneyland uh
like park segment right before the
opening of the path there's this house
it looks like a gnome house
the roof looks straight out of a tim
burton thing
so that thing is creepy yeah and there's
a lot a lot of old
victorian looking houses there which
doesn't make any sense to me because
who the [ __ ] i don't even know who would
live there who lives in whittier i don't
know
how witty or even started where is that
it's
about it it's 45 minutes east of here
yeah
i mean i guess i could see it you know
tired of the beach it's not that far
away did it feel a little
scary like did the air feel different
yeah
really no i couldn't feel any energy
no i so there's an okay
so there's a lot of myths about that
place between cults and cult ritual and
stuff
candidly i can't see it because
the trail is just too nice it's too wide
yeah you can you can drive a car through
the whole thing okay and there's a radio
tower at the top or like a water tower
so
clearly there's just some old school
like maintenance fire road [ __ ] like
it's not
you can't feel scared it's just too safe
yeah and then once you get to the top
it's or towards the top it's it's like
gravel like paved road so you're like
this ain't
was it a good hike at least it was yeah
it was it was it was decently long it
took longer than i thought
okay um people were giving me [ __ ] in
the video being like
so you're huffing and puffing after that
hike i was like [ __ ] you man
that was like six miles hiking
gatekeeper yeah yeah completely
hiking gatekeep so supposedly in
turnbull canyon i was being sarcastic
through the whole video but there's a
spot called hell's gate
i forget why they call it that but i
guess it just looks crazy because the
gate is on some dude's lawn
so over time as people have showed up
more and more he's
put more security on it to basically
like get the [ __ ] out of my house
and uh so yeah i think
that's like you know if you're like
talking about atmosphere
i really don't think that [ __ ] i think
the first segment would be scary because
of snakes
um but that's anything that's like just
shrub like you're walking through you
don't know
yeah so the one that is really scary i
guess is black star canyon and i guess
like
i don't know it's like a white supremacy
hub or something and like really
so it's like actual danger to go there
but i don't know i don't know from these
like there's actual white supremacists
there
yeah okay like that's their [ __ ] so you
know
people were like you should go there i'm
like why the in what
universe what to interview dude hey man
i just was wondering like if i could
just you know
i'm making a video for youtube about how
scary this place is
yeah what are your favorite and least
favorite races
what about annaball animal animal ah
[Music]
just a bunch of beefy yeah meatheads
yeah
what's the dudes they lift you up the
mountain
they throw you up the mountain you go up
a chain of of dudes just benching you
up they just throw you
one [ __ ] quarter mile at a time
no they're tickling you look at the gym
take a look
so you're giggling all the way up to the
top
yeah that place was hot as [ __ ] and i
wore
black like just you know idiots
yeah just trying on a hike just trying
to make it stick to boxing brother
yeah get out of here get out of our
hiking
spots dude the best [ __ ] so
i read a post on reddit you know i don't
know what that [ __ ] is
which website r-e-d-d-i-t okay it's a
financial
um it's a fight financial wellness oh
gosh
it's like a forum yeah basically an
online forum teach how to spend your
money and stuff
cool [ __ ] i saw a post that
had me laughing because i resonated with
it so much so we were going up this
trail
and this dude and his girl are hiking
and he's got his dog off his leash
and it wasn't a big dog it was big
enough you know and you know someone
else's dog you know they're gonna
[ __ ] act
and we're walking through you know dirt
road and [ __ ] you don't you don't know
if uh
i don't know if it's gonna get freaked
out or something so
you know i read this post and it was
like keep your dog
on a leash when you're hiking okay i was
like oh yeah
i know what that's like that literally
happened to me the other day
and like the first paragraph is like not
everyone likes your dog
you like your dog blah blah blah blah
and he's telling some story about how he
used to be one of those guys and his dog
sniffed out some lady who had like a
traumatic dog attack experience and she
had like a
[ __ ] meltdown because his dog
approached
her i mean that's kind of true like i've
had dogs
like sprint at chili on the beach yeah
like giant dogs
yeah and then i talked to one other guy
that was like yeah i had i had
he just like he got these new little he
had these greyhound puppies
two little greyhounds one of them was
like or they were both like either i
think they were twins or brothers or
whatever
twins yeah twin dogs does that exist
twin dogs yeah they're all twins yeah
like
siblings right yeah when they like look
like each other anyways they were like
eight months old the guy said that
he had the first time he took him to the
beach he was walking them and this
bigger dog
sprinted at one of them that was off
leash and broke the dog's fibia
nice and what the other owner said ah
yeah sorry she loves to run around just
listen
so battle listening are the dogs on the
ground bleeding
[Laughter]
come here chip yeah that was that was
like in our complex
i mentioned this way early in the
podcast where alina was just working
with the window open and she just hears
this woman like
shrieking her face off like
she looks out and she's like holding her
arm and some dude is holding onto his
[ __ ]
pitbull or whatever the [ __ ] he's like
i'm so sorry
people oh yeah like bitter oh my gosh
he says [ __ ] i pit dude it would piss me
off
at our spot because there was this we
could do
we could make a what i don't know i've
never brought this guy up
i don't know how i have never brought
this guy up this guy
oh we got a basic character on him or
something for something this is
the weirdest guy on earth hit this
massive dog had a similar coat
to ollie you know black with brown this
dog is big i almost say
ah [ __ ]
i want to say like at least 50 60 pounds
he's a [ __ ]
huge neck okay i don't know how much do
mastiffs weigh
like 180 pounds probably yeah so maybe
his dog could easily be like 50 or 60
pounds this thick [ __ ] boy
his his uh his leash was one of those
leashes where
it um
it looks like what you would put on your
tires to get tread and snow
okay you know what i'm talking about
like it's got like hooks yep and it's
metal
yeah yeah kelsey's brother has that for
his dog yeah so he's got one of those
which just makes it look worse and his
head is you know looks like dana white
like it's like swollen
yeah and big ass perfect comparison yeah
you know big neck boy and this dude
would be in the dog run you know there's
signs everywhere
keep your dog on a leash and he's
training it he throws a tennis ball and
this thing just goes
woofing down the whole runway
yeah and and and he trains it to
you know and whenever other dogs come
around he's like
come here and the dog you know listens
to him
i say i need to make a character of this
guy because
one night i go out and he's wearing a
robe
you know it's like a velvet rope it's a
nice robe okay and some sandals
and he's got his dog off leash taking it
to [ __ ] or something
and it was pretty late at night so
when i came out to the dog run he like
kind of looks over his shoulder and he's
keeping his back face
face to me and uh he like he gets his
dogs
and then he turns around real quick and
the eye contact
he made with me said to me
yeah there's no underwear here okay
there's no underwear because the the
lining came down to like
below the belly button and then that's
where the tie was
and he just kind of shuffled out of
there in a way that was just like a
little too you know normally he's missed
her like [ __ ]
but he he dipped and i'm like
who are you with your big ass dog you
got your [ __ ] meat out
under your belt i mean you know it's us
that i'm even imagining that he's
[ __ ]
get your big old meat out yeah well
you're training your dog
want to think about your big meat
swinging around while you're training
your dog
nah but this was just the funniest [ __ ]
like your dog is gonna kill another dog
and you're just out here
pretending like oh yeah you know i
trained him well
yeah he's a good he's a good puppy so
that was the same guy whose dog bit
someone's arm no no no no no no no
i don't even know what happened to that
guy okay but yeah
the dog you don't have a dog run so you
just no
dog run is a crazy place man yeah the
amount of people we've met and like i
didn't ask to meet
and like i just have a roll of decks of
dog run people yeah
like is it like a like a little social
social hour down there
it's like you know the run yeah yeah
yeah it's like it's like having
kathy see you at six the run yeah cool
bring a glass of wine it's like being
part of the soho house dude yeah
the dog one is a soho
[Laughter]
everyone talks about their dog like it's
their home girl or something
yeah something oh mitzi she's so crazy
we should work on something together
you